well today we checked back in with the
reddits am i the a-hole forum to try to
solve some moral quandaries people you
know um will ask me why i think i'm
qualified to
chime in on these kinds of issues and
the reason is that i'm an a-hole myself
and of long-standing and i have a lot of
experience in that field so that gives
me i think an important perspective on
these issues so we'll start with this um
am i the a-hole for explaining to my
friend that horses do have weight limits
it sounds like a good one already
i live and work on my parents horse
ranch where we have six quarter horses
that normally weigh
six six quarter horses like a quarter
is it a type of horse i guess uh we
normally weigh 900 to 1200 pounds the
safe and comfortable weight to be
carried in these horses is no more than
250 pounds i'm obese right now and i'm
currently on a weight loss journey
myself so i do not ride these horses
myself
because i know that i exceed the weight
that's comfortable for them a few days
ago my friend carly came over to the
ranch to help out she asked if she could
ride one of these horses carly weighs
more than i do she's also on a weight
loss journey and i explained to her
that horses have a weight limit and
that's why i don't ride them either she
got very quiet and then left she texted
me later saying i was an [ __ ] for
calling her fat
am i the insult well it's definitely a
wake-up call okay when you're too fat
the right to ride a horse that's that's
a wake-up call i see you got away from
can't wait to eat um and it goes to show
by the way that morbid obesity is a
modern invention this is something that
we invented in modern times it didn't
exist before like it just didn't it just
almost nowhere in the world could you
find it for most of human history
because if you were morbidly obese in
the 1800s you'd have to walk the oregon
trail and probably be good for you if
you did you would lose some weight now
are you the a-hole for
preventing your obese friend from
turning your horse into a horse pancake
not at
all um i'm i'm not much of an animal
rights guy but i absolutely believe that
preventing spinal injuries to your horse
is more important
than protecting your friend's feelings
but your friend is infected with his
modern attitude which says that uh that
you you're not allowed to acknowledge
uncomfortable realities about other
people or about yourself even if your
refusal to acknowledge those realities
could do real damage to both man and
beast uh you're under no obligation to
play along with that game though and
ignore reality so your friend is the
a-hole for trying to
make you play that game you call your
friend and hold this instant okay am i
the a-hole for not letting my boyfriend
give my friend a foot rub a close friend
of mine was visiting last week and
stayed at my house yesterday we went out
for a few hours and i wore heels and
encouraged her to wear a cute pair of
heels as well by the time we got back
our feet were in a lot of pain my
boyfriend gave me a foot massage as he
always does whenever my feet hurt and my
friend asks him for one as well but i
didn't feel comfortable with that and
asked him not to my friend got upset she
said that i was an a-hole for leaving
her in pain and that i was the one who
gave her the idea to wear heels for that
long but i just didn't feel comfortable
with my boyfriend giving another woman a
foot rub am i the a-hole
well you are the a-hole only for taking
your nasty feet out and asking for a
foot rub in full view of another person
you've been walking around all day
in heels and then you pull your feet out
and take your sock off i guess you
weren't probably wearing socks and
wearing heels and you're showing those
off in front of somebody else feet are
disgusting should never be seen by
anybody other than your podiatrist go
suck it but
don't worry your friend is even worse
she not only wanted to take her feet out
but actually was soliciting someone
else's boyfriend to rub them what kind
of freak are you hanging out with the
foot massage is nothing i give my mother
a foot
it's bad enough that you asked your
boyfriend to rub your feet did you even
wash your feet first
did you take a shower first before you
made this request yeah
but for her it's even more perverse and
and her reason is that she wore heels
well whose fault is that this is why you
know i don't like to hear this some of
these complaints from women about uh
it's so hard
we have to wear heels it makes our feet
her what's your decision high heels are
a cross that women are meant to bear
with stoicism and dignity
certainly not
while asking men to rub your feet um am
i the a-hole for not allowing my brother
and his wife to stay over in our family
vacation house if they bring the dogs
don't need to read the story here uh you
are not you are not the a-hole quite the
opposite i'm gonna say this because no
one else will i'm not an [ __ ] no one
should try to bring their mangy mutts
into somebody else's house it's bad
enough to have them in your own house
but to bring them some that's almost as
bad as exposing your feet he did tell
you about the feet that's why i also
don't get but back to the feet thing for
a second you know the people that are
like uh
they want you to take your shoes off in
their house
that i we don't do that in our house why
first of all it's weird
the second someone walks into your house
you're you're telling them to take off
items of clothing how far is this going
to go strip and and also i no i don't
want to see i don't even like you're
just coming in my house
i don't want to see your feet i don't
know where you've been this whole time
but anyway
taking the shoes off that's almost as
bad as bringing the dog in
and and here's my question my question
like why do we give dogs special
treatment in general in life but when it
comes to this like when it comes to pets
if i had a free-range tarantula that i
let crawl around my house
and then i came to your house and i said
oh i brought my tarantula hope you don't
mind and i just let it loose in your
living room okay you'd probably be upset
about that
how is this different what if i wanted
to bring my kangaroo to your house or my
pet crocodile no you would say what are
you doing bringing animals into my house
i invited you over you're a human i
didn't invite any am this isn't a zoo i
don't make an exception for dogs i don't
don't be initial you know you may
imagine that you have uh freedom but
it's mostly an illusion because there
are like two or three companies that
control pretty much all of our online
activity big tech is more powerful than
most countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and these tech
juggernauts and that's why i use
expressvpn think about how much of your
life is on the internet sadly every site
you visit video you watch your message
you send gets tracked and data mined but
when you run expressvpn on your device
the software hides your ip address
something big tech can use to personally
identify you so expressvpn makes your
activity harder to trace and sell to
advertisers expressvpn also encrypts 100
of your internet data to keep you safe
from hackers and eavesdroppers on your
network what i like most about
expressvpn is how easy it is to use
download the app on your phone or
computer tap one button and you're
protected and expressvpn does all this
without slowing your connection that's
why it's rated the number one vpn
service by techradar the verge and
countless others so stop handing over
your personal data to the big tech
monopoly who minds your activity and
sells your information protect yourself
with the vpn that i trust to keep me
safe online visit
expressvpn.comwalshyt to get three extra
months free
am i the a-hole for calling my brother a
mama's boy and refusing to apologize for
ruining his birthday
okay my brother and his wife live at my
mom's house mom tends to get involved in
their marriage constantly and my brother
lets her sister-in-law always complains
about mom steamrolling her and her
decisions and violating her privacy when
sister-in-law got pregnant mom got worse
she went out and bought a whole nursery
and put it in her room despite
sister-in-law having one in her room the
most recent conflict is about mom
pushing to be in the delivery room and
sister-in-law saying no
my brother not only is siding with mom
but he's making promises to her to keep
her happy
uh last week we were gathered at mom's
house for my brother's birthday his
friends came and asked why sister-in-law
wasn't at dinner table my brother
nonchalantly said that she was just
being a princess acting spoiled and
immature over everything i was shocked
and hurt on her behalf so i responded
actually she's probably just upset now
that she realizes that you're a grade a
mama's boy ready to do whatever mom says
while ignoring your wife's wishes brief
silence while his friend stared he
started arguing about how disrespectful
i was he told my husband uh
to say something and my husband just
said don't mind me
i'm just a bystander
well your husband real brave on your
husband's part
what's what's up with the men in these
fam this this family here dinner got
awkward and my brother's friends left
early he went off on me saying i
embarrassed him before his friends and
ruined his birthday dinner i decided to
go home because he kept yelling mom then
called demanding i apologize for the
rude things i said at dinner table but i
refused i think first of all you and
your sister have similar problems like
you both uh you both chose some winners
here so
you're getting screamed at and your
husband just sitting there don't mind me
i'm just a bystander coward no you're
not the a-hole here i mean i think you
did the right thing the first problem
here is that your your brother is a
grown man
throwing a birthday party for himself
and you know how i feel about that
as a grown adult and you're throwing a
birthday party for yourself and then
crying
because someone ruined it you ruined my
birthday
what are you five years old apparently
so at least emotionally and mentally to
be expected from an adult man who still
lives at home demands his mommy take his
side in arguments and look leaving all
that aside
just a
a quick tip here for it should be pretty
obvious but there are many married
couples who don't seem to understand
this
in a marriage um you never complain
about
or insult your spouse publicly in front
of others now you shouldn't insult your
spouse at all it's not a good thing to
do but if you're gonna have a heated
disagreement
and there's gonna be and if there's
gonna be rude things said back and forth
and it shouldn't happen but it happens
sometimes in a marriage
you never bring other people in on that
okay you you never do that
it's never the right thing and it's so
you you have to
it blows my mind when i encounter people
this is so common like married couples
they don't understand first of all
your loyalty should be to your spouse
first and foremost that's the
relationship that should be the most
meaningful to you in the entire world
that's the relationship that you that
takes number one priority is your
relationship to your spouse even above
your kids your relationship to your
spouse is even more important than your
relationship to your kids that comes
first
because that's what your kids need your
kids need your mom and dad to have a
good relationship so it's for their sake
also
that you work on that relationship first
and then everything flows down from
there
all right am i the a-hole for eating
cake in my car so i didn't have to share
with my wife and kids
i acknowledge as a father and husband
that a lot of things that were
singularly mine just before now aren't
the wife steals my clothes wife and kids
steal my food kids steal my phone the
stealing the clothes thing is is that's
really a thing i mean all this is a
thing this is the stuff that wife and
kids do
the stealing clothing that's one i
didn't quite
expect ahead of time like my wife and i
are not the same size thankfully and but
she she like take my sweatpants she'll
take my you know my slippers she's
always stealing those they don't fit her
at all they're all so gross like why
would you want to wear my slippers have
you seen my feet
speaking of feet enough um anyway they
steal all these things and usually i'm
fine with it but i just needed one thing
to myself without hurting feelings and
making someone cry
because everybody is sensitive in this
house including me
i bought a single serve piece of cake
and ate it in my car without any wife
sneaking bits or kids licking the
chocolate from the top unfortunately i
got caught my wife is upset with me for
going so far as to eat cake while hiding
in my car and called me dramatic when i
told her my reasoning am i the a-hole no
you're not remotely the a-hole not at
all
you
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
you're cool
you as the man of the house have a right
to eat some damned cake every once in a
while without a bunch of piranhas
swarming you and and nibbling at it
your only mistake was eating the cake i
guess did you eat it in the car
in your own at your own house like in
your driveway you snuck out that's a
rookie move
you don't do that
or or did she discover the
packaging or something like that no um
what you do is you you go and you get
the cake or whatever snack you want at
the store of the restaurant you eat it
in the parking lot
and this is why in any
restaurant park store parking lot you
look around
in pretty much any parking lot anytime
you're going to see men alone in cars
eating this is a thing that we do it's
the one place we get some peace and
quiet it's our sanctuary and uh so you
eat in the car and then you throw away
the evidence and then you drive home
i've been through this many times you
know i have snacks in my house
that are supposed to be just for me so i
have to hide them you can also do that
but that's a tough that could be a tough
move sometimes but you hide your snacks
like like sacred artifacts you hide them
away
for example i really enjoy fruit snacks
yes i like fruit snacks as a grown man
what of it
got something to say about that i do
like frozen snacks i like the motz fruit
snacks or scooby-doo don't bring any of
that welsh's around me i don't eat that
but
if i bring a box of fruit snacks home
my kids will consume the entire thing
including the box within an hour so i
have to hide it i have to like climb a
mountain and bury it up there or or
descend into a cavern into a cave like
gollum if anyone comes into the cave and
wants a fruit snack i have to ask them
three riddles you know it's a whole
thing it's weird anyway you're not the
a-hole uh not at all you did the right
thing you just you're incompetent in
this case you'll get better with time uh
for your own sake you have to and there
we go look at that
nobody was the a-hole today there were
no a-hills i am i am merciful or maybe i
just sympathize with jerks i don't know
that's also possible
well there were no a-holes today but uh
if you don't want to break that streak
and become an [ __ ] yourself to make
sure that you hit like you subscribe and
make sure to hit that notification bell